The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GARY GENSLER: So we're
going to come back again
today to blockchain economics.
A lot of what we're going to
talk about today while again
anchored in the
readings will also
be relevant as we
now turn to after Sip
week to act three where
we're going through use cases
but also hopefully relevant as
you're starting to think, OK,
what about this final
project and so forth
and what do we need to do?
Five or six of the groups
have come in either
as an individual person or teams
of three or four have come in
and bounced ideas off of me.
So I want to thank all of
the groups that have come in,
because you've helped
me also organize
some of my talking
points for today
as to what we're going through.
And those of you
who haven't come in,
feel free to set things
up if you find it helpful.
It's not mandatory.
But you can also
thank the six groups
that have come in,
because now I'm
trying to anticipate
your questions as well
along the way.
So, the overview of course our
reading and study questions
will come through.
There was the letter
to Jamie Dimon.
So we're going to dive
into that one a little bit.
I found it interesting when
I read it about a year ago.
And then I thought, why not
throw it into to the mix here?
The McKinsey report,
which, again, I
found this to be true for years.
It's not just this
class that you
can find some consultant that's
put a generalized paper out,
it does sort of
just skim the tops,
but you're getting a
sense of how they're
trying to gin up business.
Their business model is to
write some of these reports.
And some of you are going
to go into consulting
and maybe even write these
reports at some point in time.
But it's often a good way
to see what I'll call it
just a survey, a
topical survey in how
folks think about things.
Quickly a little bit
on potential use cases.
In the heart of
today's discussion
and kind of the
heart for thinking
about the final projects
is how to really assess
the costs and benefits of
any potential use case.
So I'll skip through
the study questions.
But these are the key.
I didn't see anybody go
in the discussion board.
I looked.
Did you see anything there?
No.
we did set it up.
But what are the
potential benefits,
and how do you assess
the cost of trusts?
And that is going to be true
in every single project you
look at.
If you take anything
from this class,
it's this core critical
reasoning of like--
and hopefully after
the Roubini paper
last Tuesday, we're going
to come out of the doldrums
and we're going to pull back
out of the minimalist side
and get more in the middle.
I might not get Alin lean
out of the minimalist side,
I don't know.
But it's interesting.
Some groups come in and I find
the three or four people that
are sitting there I ask.
In and even amongst
the group, there's
somebody who's a maximalist and
somebody who's a minimalist.
So I think we're being
successful that we're not
going to come out all
in the same place.
So, of course, since we're
going to talk about the reading,
let's jumped through, a
letter to Jamie Dimon.
Anybody want to tell me what
you took from that letter?
AUDIENCE: I really
loved this article.
It is my favorite
reading so far.
GARY GENSLER: Oh my
gosh, 12 classes.
All right.
AUDIENCE: So I though
that he really great
job of stripping some of the
hyperbole, both the maximalist
and the minimalist hyperbole
surrounding this out
of it to lean on
really what it is
and a very good explanation
of how it works.
And then also, the
note of caution
to see if these are the
dimensions around which--
you should wait til
you put a word in,
but these are the
reasons why there's
potentially big implications.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
And he wants to add to it.
I'm going to hold-- there
was a hand before Alin?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no.
I actually was going to
say something similar.
But I thought he highlighted a
lot the trade-off between trust
and the decentralized
properties of blockchain
versus the cost you
must be willing to pay.
GARY GENSLER: And remind
me your first name.
AUDIENCE: Leonardo.
GARY GENSLER: Leonardo.
All right.
AUDIENCE: I agree
with both of them.
Also, very good
writing and style.
One thing that I didn't
like is that at some point,
he raised the
question, well, who
needs censorship resistance?
Because it seems like
this is the only benefit
of these decentralized
applications.
And he didn't answer
that question actually.
He just gave two
vague broad answers,
but didn't answer that question.
So I think that's a
really good question.
Who needs this stuff, anyway?
GARY GENSLER: All right.
Censorship resistance.
We're going to come back to it.
Stephanie.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So actually, I thought
censorship resistance was also
one of the more interesting
parts of this letter.
Because to me, when you read
through what they highlighted
that Jamie Dimon had
said, one of the things
was people who use Bitcoin
or Blockchain are criminals.
And I didn't find that his
focus on censorship resistance
really rebutted Jamie
Dimon's argument.
GARY GENSLER: So--
Sean.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I think that
censorship resistance is really
interested in a way that
now I actually almost feel
why we spend so much time and
energy on trying to understand
public policy or
why is public policy
such a big thing in response
to decentralized apps.
I think this is a key question.
GARY GENSLER: So I think of--
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to--
well, I definitely agree.
Because that was one of Dimon's
points, that, well, yeah,
if you're a criminal,
this could be useful.
And then he talked
about how it's
worse than a lot of aspects
except censorship resistance.
But I think the
analogy he used was
the rise in encrypted messaging
that has just become--
it wasn't really
predictable that that
would be such a big thing,
but now that's gotten
use cases in the world.
GARY GENSLER: So it
seems like people really
like the writing,
not just the style
but that it took on and
had a balanced approach.
But you're highlighting,
wait a minute,
he ends with
censorship resistance,
but then doesn't
take it the next way.
Like, what does that mean?
And so I think
we're going to try
to tease that out a little
bit, but I think of it
as in two ways.
It's the individual.
Any one of us could be
blocked from doing something.
We could not get a
service, we could not
be allowed to take credit if
somebody is allocating credit.
Think about Uber.
If Uber were censoring, we
can't get a ride any longer.
How many of us rate
everybody a five when
we ride our Ubers
because we think,
well, maybe they'll pick me up.
If I rated everybody a three,
maybe they'll censor me.
I don't know, but maybe you all
give more legitimate feedback.
I just hit five.
So it's the
individual censorship,
but I think of it as
a second thing also,
is barriers to entry, a
commercial more broad market
barrier.
And that in some ways,
the blockchain technology
might allow to build something
where incumbents already
have barriers to entry.
They might have used public
policy to get the barriers,
by the way.
They might have regulatory
barriers as well.
But more specifically,
he did define--
it was kind of
interesting-- crypto assets.
And he was one that--
I'm trying to remember
the gentleman who wrote it
because it was on Chain.
It was the head of Chain.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Adam Ludwin.
GARY GENSLER: Adam Ludwin.
But he too said, let's not
use the word cryptocurrency.
Let's use the word
crypto assets.
They enable a
decentralized application.
And that was a key thing he was
trying to say to Jamie Dimon.
It depends on how
much you believe
in decentralized applications.
If you don't see a value in
decentralized applications,
Ludwin, said, all
right, I get it,
I'll agree with you, Mr. Dimon.
But there is a benefit for
decentralized applications
and a mechanism to
allocate resources
to a specific organization.
So some incentive way, some
way to allocate resources.
I would say this.
We've studied money
a lot this semester,
the medium of exchange, unit
of a cat, store of value.
But it's also possible that
these crypto assets have
some other benefit, that they're
not really truly competing
with the US dollar or
competing with the Euro,
but maybe they're competing
with-- who's my friend who's
the gamer over here?
Skins, yeah.
What's your name again?
AUDIENCE: Mike.
GARY GENSLER: Mike.
I'm going to be always
looking to my right for the--
but it could be an
incentive and be competing
with skins, in a sense.
And so I took that,
that, Mr. Dimon,
don't think of it only
versus the Euro or the Dollar
because maybe you're right.
But it could have
something to do
with decentralized applications.
Kelly.
AUDIENCE: To add to that,
Bitcoin is capitalism still.
He should love it.
GARY GENSLER: That
you should still
love Bitcoin and capitalism,
and that the banks
aren't going away.
They will probably
still have banks.
AUDIENCE: It is incredible
that he didn't use the word
blockchain till the very
end to asterisk and say,
you'll notice I
don't use blockchain,
and I thought kind of a genius
way to separate [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: Right.
I'm not as genius as him
because the whole course
is called Blockchain and Money.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, well.
So what are decentralized
applications, at least
in this write-up?
Anybody?
Kelly?
AUDIENCE: Basically, it just
says it allows you [INAUDIBLE]
but without the trust part.
GARY GENSLER: So you don't need
a centralized trusted party.
That's what in the 1990s so many
people tried and failed with,
in a sense.
And the internet became this
way, in a decentralized way,
to distribute packets
of information,
even though there is
centralization on the internet
as well, as we discussed
Tuesday and so forth.
But this decentralized
application-- so
in this context, he
was using it broader
than just something
built on top of Ethereum
through smart contracts.
Because he even said Bitcoin
was a decentralized application.
So he was using it in
the broader context,
not in what some people
would call dapps.
But a new model for creating
financing operating software.
And this is what Christian
Catalini wrote about as well,
that it might be that there's
a new way to finance a software
development.
Maybe raise some money
for the file sharing
before you have
the file sharing.
Might be an incentive
system as well.
And then he talked about
two structural trade-offs
from the design.
Now, this blockchain design
has a lot of complexity.
It has a lot of additional
cost, whether it's mining costs
for proof of work
or some other cost
to basically secure the data.
And so there has
to be a trade-off.
And what can pull you out of
the minimalist end of this
is whether there's
some benefits as well.
And we're going
to chat about that
in five or 10 minutes again.
And then the
censorship resistance.
These are my words, not his.
I really do think it's
the individual censorship,
but also, what I'll
broadly call the market.
Are there barriers to entry
in the current system that
are, in essence, censoring
economic activity broadly,
not individually?
And I think, though, that
was not how he defined
it-- and I agree with Alin.
It would have been great if
he had written a few more
paragraphs or another page.
But I think it's not
just the individual,
it's some barriers to entry
for whole market structures.
And often, centralized
institutions,
because they have such
a networking effect,
it's hard to break in
when somebody is basically
the hub of a hub and spokes
network for almost anything.
How do you topple Facebook
at this point in time?
Because it can censor other
market activity, as an example.
So then we had the
McKinsey report.
Anything that people took
from yet one more survey paper
that you've had?
Akira?
It's just because I can see
your name on the board there.
AUDIENCE: From [INAUDIBLE],, I
found the use case [INAUDIBLE]
use case to be [INAUDIBLE].
And one thing I
found interesting
is the switching costs.
Because the incumbent
financial institutions
have to think about not only the
benefit of the cost reduction,
but also, we have to think about
[INAUDIBLE] costs, existing
infrastructure, a lot of
the affect on the people
watching [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: So Akira's
raised a very important thing
about switching costs.
And we wrote about this, even
though I'm not detailing it
again, in the joint paper that
Simon, Johnson, and Nihon,
and Michael, and
Joan, and I wrote.
Now, this the last time--
it's the third time you had to
come back and supposedly read
a little bit more of
the Geneva Report.
But we talked there about
the switching cost as well.
And by the way,
to Alin's question
from Tuesday about
interoperability,
a lot of switching costs
relate to interoperability.
If you're an
institution and you're
thinking about putting in
place some blockchain solution,
permissioned or permissionless,
but how does it communicate
with the existing network?
If the Australian
stock exchange is
putting in a new back end
clearing and settlement system
on a blockchain--
and they are and they're
using digital asset holding--
they have to think about,
well, all of our customers
are currently communicating
with a legacy database system.
And now we're creating
a blockchain system.
How does that communicate?
How does the old system
literally move information over
into the new system?
And all of those from
a business perspective
are a question of how do
you operate or interoperate
with the legacy system
and all the network.
Because any blockchain
solution that you're
going to come up
with is likely to be
replacing some other economic
activity, and likely,
you're not going to try to
replace the entire network.
You're going to be surgical.
You're going to decide--
I'm not trying to
give anything, Eric,
but can I say what you
all are talking about it
in your final project?
You have intellectual
property, so I don't
know if you wanted to share it.
But do you want to say what--
AUDIENCE: Could you
elaborate a little more?
In the point we were
discussing, I was kind of lost.
GARY GENSLER: Well,
so Eric's group--
and Brotish, and
Catalina, and Ross--
are talking about maybe doing
a permissioned blockchain
application for credit reports.
Not credit reports for
the commercial side,
but consumer credit.
Basically, an-- uh-oh, Alf.
Are you competing with them?
Did I just--
AUDIENCE: No, no.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
All right.
Maybe you are, so I
shouldn't say much more.
No, it's all right.
But I won't say anything more.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it would
be interesting to point out
the fundamental--
or one of the interesting
things that comes up
from the discussion of
the topic we're engaging
is how to approach a
blockchain solution
from an entrepreneurial
perspective.
Going back to the letter to--
GARY GENSLER: Jamie Dimon.
AUDIENCE: To Jamie
Dimon reading,
we're trying to get
rid of intermediaries
or getting economic rents with
that differing kind of paradigm
that justifies the costs of
using a blockchain approach
to promote [INAUDIBLE].
But from an entrepreneurial
point of view,
you would end up trying to get
some benefit from that kind
of implementation.
So you don't want to
replace intermediaries
with another intermediary.
So you would have to be
really creative in terms
of how to come up with really
lowering costs and gaining
some profits in the process.
GARY GENSLER: So Eric's
raising that if you're just
replacing one intermediary
with another intermediary,
will you be successful
as an entrepreneur?
Yes, if you're providing a
better service or a lower cost
structure, lower economic rents.
So I wouldn't doubt yourself.
I would say, we might
be able to do it.
In your use case--
and apologies,
maybe it's multiple use--
maybe it's two or three
groups thinking about it.
There's a lot of market power
right now, and thus a lot
of economic rents, but a lot of
market power and economic rents
and credit reporting.
Equifax, First Union, and
others earn a certain fees
for all of those FICA scores.
In the US, we use this.
If you're getting
a job, somebody
runs a credit report on you.
If you're buying an automobile
and taking out an auto loan.
It feels like each
of us probably
have a credit report pulled
on us multiple times a year.
Sometimes we don't even know it.
But back to interoperability
and switching
costs, just to pull
it all together.
How could you convince the
commercial banks to use--
I'll call it Eric's
project, it's
four people, but how could you
convince all the banks to use
their project and how about
all the auto dealerships
on the other side who right
now are very comfortable using
First Union?
Everybody's probably
paying a little bit extra.
And there's a fat market
power, economic rents.
And so that's part of
the switching costs
that Akira mentioned.
And to the
interoperability, I believe
they'll be more
successful if they
don't try to completely
change how data flows,
that at some point
you need to know
that you can't be
successful by biting off
too much all at once.
I'm sorry, Catalina.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say that, precisely, that
is one of the
forms of blockchain
he raised in the paper.
And it's not changing one
intermediary for another.
Financially, what they
say is that he's going
to be more successful for--
blockchain's going to be more
successful in the permissioned
than in the permissionless
because the incumbents are more
willing to work on
the permissioned
than with the permissionless.
GARY GENSLER: In
essence, Catalina
is saying you might be
more successful not trying
to disrupt the entire
community, whatever
that community in some
ecosystem, some business
community, and do
it in a permissioned
versus permissionless.
But we're going to play
with that a little longer.
Kelly.
AUDIENCE: I feel like they
addressed the timeline of where
the strategic value is.
For example, they
said, currently
the best way to reap the
benefits from blockchain
are to focus on
this, this, and this.
And then they say, however,
feasibility at scale, they say,
is probably three
to five years away,
exactly what you've been saying.
So--
GARY GENSLER: Oh, my god.
We could both be wrong.
All right.
Jack.
AUDIENCE: Something else
I found interesting.
There's a lot of talk right now
about robotics and supply chain
using blockchain.
And the McKinsey report
kind of touched on that.
No matter how secure
the blockchain
is, when you start involving
actual real products
and assets, it could be
completely corrupted,
even if the blockchain folds.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
And also, it's interesting--
I think, Jack, if I can
pick further on that.
When you have something
on the blockchain,
even if it arguably
should be there,
it's a property
right and so forth,
but it's an off-chain asset,
it's not just a digital asset,
and secured and verified
on a blockchain.
But in supply chain, it's often
an off-chain asset, and often
a physical asset.
Then there's
additional challenges.
I think there's some really
interesting use cases,
but it's a little bit
of a different place.
James.
And then I'm going to-- no?
So McKinsey defines
a blockchain.
And they point out
it doesn't have
to necessarily disintermediate
to generate value.
I thought that was an
interesting intuition.
Don't always think that
you have to disintermediate
to generate value.
They might be right or
they might be wrong.
But you might
actually still end up
with something that's kind of--
as-- did Catalina say it?
I can't remember
now who said it,
but they also said
they gave a timescale.
A short term value
might be predominantly--
Kelly did, sorry-- three
to five years away.
How to capture value.
Be pragmatic and
skeptical, but you
need to go down to
a granular level.
And that's also what
I'm going to ask
you to do in the
final paper, is really
to challenge yourself,
challenge your group
to go down to the granular
level and say, wait,
what transactions
are we actually going
to change the flow?
What ledger system
might we shift?
And even though it's
the back office--
and to some people,
you might say, oh,
my god, that's kind of the
boring side of business.
But that's really what
blockchain is about.
It's a database and ledger
management system also.
And to be successful,
you have to get down
to that granular level
and figure it out
in terms of whatever
that current ecosystem is
or the regulatory system.
They said it's particularly
valuable in low trust
environments.
And that could be
where currently we
can't trade directly and you've
created a new way to do peer
to peer, or where
there's not currently
a central intermediary.
You can go right at it.
You could be like this
bold group that says,
I want to take on Transunion,
I want to take on Equifax.
That's something which is a
central intermediary right now.
But it is correct, we're
not really trading directly.
It's not like when I walk into
the auto shop or to buy a car
and I'm going to take a loan
out that I can transact.
They want to validate that I
can pay back that darn loan.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just two points,
particularly the fact where
your--
well, you can't
trade directly now,
but there's a lot
of trade happening
where you don't have
an intermediary,
but some sort of
intermediary would help.
I couldn't help but think
of ag markets in very--
GARY GENSLER: You're saying
ag, like agriculture?
AUDIENCE: Agriculture markets in
very remote parts of the world,
where actually being networked.
And precisely, there's no trust.
That kind of environment exists.
So a good use case for
that, extreme remote parts
of the world where internet
is there, but not necessarily
financial institutions or
regulatory environments.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
And there are many parts,
particularly in the third world
that are still unbanked.
I've said this statistic before,
but the World Bank report
on banking in 2017, half
of sub-Saharan African
was still unbanked.
But half of that half
has mobile phones.
So it's just-- those gaps might
change, but then it will move.
Yes, they might have
a banking account,
but it would be not
something they can really
do with agriculture.
So two opportunities--
and I'm going
to come to the
question-- is like,
do you go head-on against
a central intermediary
and use this technology
to do it better?
[PHONE RINGING]
Look at that.
I should turn this off.
Head-on against a
central intermediary?
Or some market structure
that has no really core
intermediary, but you can
build a better trustless
peer to peer network?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] that's
when it comes to
private permission.
Architectural blockchain,
it's highly likely
to be more scalable.
Why is that?
GARY GENSLER: Highly likely
to be more scalable, yes.
So permissioned blockchains,
they've made a trade-off.
So Nakamoto's paper comes out.
For a few years, people
don't really notice it.
But then it starts
to get some lift
and folks are looking
at it in 2013 to 2015.
And the financial industry
starts to think about this
and says, this actually
is pretty interesting.
We're not sure what
it's going to do,
but we're pretty interested.
And they get attracted to
it because it might be a way
to move data around, it might
be able to literally lower
the costs of the back office.
Many banks keeping the
same set of records--
I have an equity
trading business,
you have an equity
trading business.
We both have to confirm
and correct those records.
But we keep full databases.
What they found
attractive was real.
But then remember,
Bitcoin can only
do seven transactions a second.
So all of those challenges of
scalability, privacy, security
led them to think
about, was there
a way that we could
literally toss
some of the technical
things over the side?
And most of them thought, we
don't need a native token.
We don't need an
incentive structure.
And if we limit the number
of nodes in the network,
we can increase
scalability and we
can get rid of proof of work.
So my narrative
might not matter,
but it's important
to understand it.
The permissionless thing comes
along, and then they say,
it's not scalable.
What can we toss overboard
and make it scalable?
And what they tossed overboard--
they didn't even feel they
needed the native token,
and they tossed overboard
proof of work, consensus,
and had a club deal.
In the Australian
stock exchange example,
they might only have
two or three nodes.
But in some of these,
there's 15 or 20.
So why is it more scalable?
Fewer nodes and much more
efficient consensus mechanisms.
But the trade-off is
you better damn well
trust now those 15 or 20 nodes.
And when we talk
about 51% attacks,
you could revise a whole
permissioned blockchain
if those 15 parties wanted to.
Now, some people say, well, you
could just do a hash function.
Remember that whole hashing.
You could do a hash function of
a whole permissioned blockchain
once a day, once a
week, once an hour
and store it somewhere else.
In fact, you could store the
hash of all of that on Bitcoin.
You could use a
ledger like Bitcoin
and just store it there.
So there's some feedback loops.
Does that help?
Give you a sense?
AUDIENCE: I was also just
going to build on that.
So the power of a
permissioned blockchain
is that, unlike Ethereum or
Bitcoin, it's not public.
So there is no public ledger.
You can make it public,
but it's permissioned, not
permissionless.
Because you need to have trusted
entities in this network.
So this can also
be, you could say,
a feature, not a bug
when it comes to scaling.
Because essentially,
you control the scale.
So you control these nodes.
And then like
mentioned, these nodes
are only relevant
because they are
trusted pieces of this puzzle.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I think it's easier
to get scale,
but there is not a
large enough market
to actually make
it scale or make
it reach to the critical mass.
GARY GENSLER: So are you
worried that there's not
enough to get to
the critical mass?
Now, I'm not sure--
so a permissionless blockchain
and a permissioned blockchain
both can be open
to public users.
You can have millions of people
use a permissioned blockchain,
but only 15 have the right
to amend the records.
So one might think
of who has a right
to read it, who has a
right to write on it.
Read, write.
But also, absent even that,
it might provide a service,
like file sharing
or some service.
There might even be
a third list of who
has a right to use the service.
Now, usually to use a
service, you actually
have to read the data.
But you could partition and say,
how much can be read as well.
Yes, and remind me
of your first name.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I really appreciate
your perspective
from how you
envision [INAUDIBLE]
permissioned projects.
GARY GENSLER: The
pathway, you said?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in
terms of its relationship with
[INAUDIBLE].
Do you think it
would pave the way
towards the true
decentralization eventually?
Or you were just [INAUDIBLE]
Or you would just
become irrelevant just as the
intranet compared to internet.
GARY GENSLER: So [INAUDIBLE]
question is unanswerable,
but I'll try to give my opinion
in 2018, and then we'll see.
And it's being recorded,
so we'll see how I'll do.
But the question
really is, what's
the relationship for
permissioned and permissionless
blockchains?
And what is it going
to be longer term?
I think today in 2018, because
of the scalability issues
and some of the
privacy and security
issues, the dominant place
that the investment will
be is on the permissioned
side, especially
with what's called enterprise
applications, the banks,
the large institutions.
There's not enough scalability
because 1,000 users a day
or 1,500 users a
day on the big apps
right now on the Ethereum
network, that's just not
enough beyond gaming sites
and some small hobbyist type
things, like CryptoKitties.
It's fun, it's
interesting, but it's not
truly scalable to 7 billion
people living around the globe.
But I wouldn't-- and I've
said this to some IBM folks.
And they have 1,000 people at
IBM in the hyper ledger team.
Anybody who is a
blockchain minimalist--
you haven't heard this number?
AUDIENCE: I've heard 2,500.
GARY GENSLER: 2,500?
All right.
So it's more than I thought.
So 1,000 to 2,500.
I knew it was more than 1,000.
IBM is throwing a
lot of money there.
Now, they might be doing
that to protect their risk.
They might be investing even
if all those 1,000 people
ultimately produce nothing.
But I think that five years from
now or seven years from now,
the gap will close.
I think that permissionless
systems will always
have a lot of challenge about
governance, collective action.
How you have collective
action is not just
a matter of technical and
coding and smart scientist
at MIT and elsewhere.
I think that's going to
still be a challenge,
and there will be trade-offs.
So it might be
that they coexist,
but I think the gap will close.
And you said, well, will it
be like the intranet went away
and the internet was there.
There are some people
that believe that.
And that might be--
I'm probably not there.
I'm probably not
all the way there.
But I think when
the gap closes, some
of these permissioned systems
will not be as necessary.
Zero knowledge
proofs, other ways
that come along that
make it more usable.
Yes, Zann.
AUDIENCE: Totally understood.
I'm a little bit skeptical on
the permissioned blockchains.
One of the--
GARY GENSLER: Are
you skeptical--
if I can interrupt you--
and thus it moves you over
to traditional databases?
Or skeptical and you're moved
over to permissionless open?
So I don't know, which
way is it pushing you?
AUDIENCE: Depending
on the use case.
For enterprises, I think
traditional databases
for the enterprise use case.
Reading here, this
line killed me.
It said, "Accenture developed
immutable blockchain
in which the content
of individual blocks
can be modified."
It's a ridiculous statement
considering the definition
of blockchain is anti--
this is the antithesis
of basically--
GARY GENSLER: Right.
So Accenture created an
immutable blockchain that
isn't immutable, is what you're
saying, it can be amended.
So it's a backdoor I can change.
And yet, the economics of it
is that a lot of times, people
do want a backdoor.
And the challenges-- and these
are the weaknesses as well,
as Nouriel Roubini says.
Why would you create a
system where if you forget
your private key,
lose your private key,
or the cave collapses-- that
you're hiding the private key
in a cave and maybe it floods--
that you've lost your assets?
Wouldn't you want a backdoor?
But I respect-- you would say
this isn't even a blockchain.
I'm trying to teach this
class in a little bit
neutral between permissionless
and permissioned blockchains.
But you need
something to get out
of the traditional databases.
And I've chosen, at least for
purposes of this class, that
means you've got to
have an append-only log,
you have to have time stamping.
So the basis of multiple
people writing to the ledger,
even if it's only three or five.
But these are not
well-defined vocabulary terms.
Alin.
AUDIENCE: This is why we
should stop using them.
And this is a
perfect opportunity
to actually talk about
append-only ledgers
because that's
actually meaningful--
a meaningful notion that's
been studied in computer
science for decades.
Or consensus
algorithms, which is
another meaningful notion
studied in computer
science for decades.
And consensus algorithms on
append-only ledgers, sometimes
referred to colloquially
as blockchain,
and then we would know what
are we actually talking about.
If we--
[LAUGHTER]
GARY GENSLER: Well,
I will try to help.
But we're only 80 people,
and there is a lot
of people using these terms.
And when you go outside
of this class or even
when you read an open
letter to Jamie Dimon--
of the somewhere between 25
and 50 readings you had so far
this semester, they've
used the word blockchain
in multiple ways.
I'm agreeing with you.
You're just asking me not to
ever use the word blockchain
again?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, my god.
And he's sitting in the
center of the class.
Let's keep going.
So we're going to study these.
This is just this list
that we've talked about.
But in Act Three, we're going
to come to it after SIP week
and start to go through
venture capital payment systems
and so forth.
It might be some of
what you're picking up
for the final projects.
But here-- and I stress the
word, potential use cases.
Will these all work?
Will they be places?
In the non-financial space,
supply chain management
I put on this list, but
it's kind of financial
and I wanted to include it.
Digital identity is both within
finance and outside of finance.
Property and asset registries--
you can call it finance,
but I'm not going to
dig into that a lot
in the rest of the semester.
Medical records, internet
of things, and so forth.
This isn't going
to be exhaustive.
If you come on Tuesday, October
30, to the Bitcoin blockchain
dinner that Simon
Johnson sponsors,
we'll have somebody doing
election and voting.
So there's a lot of other
interesting applications.
I tend to be a little
doubtful about the voting
because I think official sector
and governments want something
so centralized in that.
But maybe it will be
more decentralized.
Maybe it's append-only
without a consensus.
McKinsey, they broke it
down into six buckets.
They had the record keeping
and the transaction-based.
And a lot of these are
the similar buckets.
It's just to give a
spur to all of it.
So accessing costs and benefits.
So we've talked about
what are the benefits.
These are the questions
that I would be saying.
And some of this was
in the Geneva Report,
but rather than
trying to tease it out
of all of the discussion, here
I would lay out four big buckets
as to how I think about this and
how I might get your feedback.
If you see other
ways to look at this,
I want to learn from
you all as well.
And when I say four,
this is the first bucket.
Basically, what are the benefits
of using this technology?
Whether it's this idea about
consumer credit or some of you
have had ideas about
government procurement
or payments, wherever you
are, what is the true benefit?
You've got to find a pain point.
Every entrepreneur always has
to find a pain point, something
that you can be solving it
for a group of stakeholders.
And who are the stakeholders
you're solving something for?
Or if you're a company, is
it an internal pain point?
Pain point is some
constraint to making
more profits, more revenues.
Or it's a friction,
it's a cost and you
want to get rid of a cost.
But what is the pain point
for providing a good service
or making more money?
How can you capture the value?
As an entrepreneur,
if you do something
for eleemosynary
purposes, meaning
you don't care
about making money,
I applaud that, that's terrific.
You can even hand that in
for your final project.
But I'm assuming that you're
going to be thinking like me,
how do you capture value?
Not only do something, but
also capture that value
and get a little of somebody
else's economic rents
if possible.
Thirdly, what are the
competition doing?
What are the competitors doing?
Even if they're using
traditional databases,
how are they addressing the
same pain point in anything
you're doing?
And why is blockchain
technology--
or, as Alin would
wish me to say,
why are append-only longs
and consensus protocols--
what is the answer?
What is it about append-only
logs with their time
stamping, with their
final settlement,
the finality of that
settlement, what about that?
Or even a full consensus
protocol and a native currency.
So I'd add a third thing because
permissionless would also
have an incentive system
in a native currency.
So what is it about append-only
logs, consensus protocol,
and a native currency?
How am I doing?
AUDIENCE: I love this.
GARY GENSLER: You love it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Talk like
this all the time.
Don't forget it.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
Oh, my god.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, I need this.
But that's the core.
And I talk about it
being the final project,
but this is going on right
now. $28 billion dollars
has been raised in
initial coin offerings
and a few extra billion,
3 or 4 other billion
has been raised by direct
venture capital in this world,
but call it $30 billion.
It's not fully mature,
but it's maturing,
and a lot of venture capitalists
are saying, wait a minute,
wait a minute, we're
past the hype stage.
What pain point are
you trying to address?
How are you creating value?
What are the competitions doing?
And why do you need append-only
logs, consensus protocols,
and possibly native tokens?
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
follow-up on that point about
the Accenture--
GARY GENSLER: You're
not going to tell me
how to define something?
All right, Kelly.
AUDIENCE: The Accenture thing
he was talking about from the--
GARY GENSLER: It's
immutable but amendable.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So we ask ourselves
the question--
that seems a little bit--
it defeats the purpose, right?
So I then ask myself, what value
is being created by doing that?
If it's not necessarily
for their customers,
where is the
internal value lying?
GARY GENSLER: I don't know
what the application was.
But I think that in every
application that we find,
not just in blockchain
but in other applications,
you have to ask absolute
final settlement.
If you can never amend it,
if it is truly immutable,
what cost does that also make?
I assume that in
this application
that was too great
a cost for them
and they wanted
a backdoor, a way
to amend that which was
supposed to be immutable.
Again, I don't know
that application.
But that is one of the--
I think it's a
feature of blockchain.
But it's both a
feature and, to some,
a bug that you cannot
amend something.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It says that one
of the benefits was
that it allowed different
entities involved
to draw on the same record.
So yeah, of course, I can
see where that's valuable.
But then it also
begs the question,
if you want to change
it, then why not just
use a traditional database?
GARY GENSLER: Vitalik
Buterin in 2016
helped when an organization
called DAO, the DAO--
is it Decentralized
Autonomous Organization?
Thank you for those who--
it was one of the largest at
the time initial coin offerings.
It raised about $160 US million.
And very quickly, right
in the smart contract--
it wasn't in the
base Ethereum layer,
but I believe it was in
the smart contract on top,
somebody saw what has
later been called a bug.
I don't know if
it's truly a bug.
It was programmed
in, in a sense,
but there was a way that they
could see how to get in there.
And they took about a
third of the tokens,
so the equivalent of
about $50 million.
But the way the
programming worked,
there was about two weeks before
it actually was truly final.
It was something in the code
also, and that wasn't a bug.
And the whole Ethereum
community was debating it.
And Vitalik Buterin said,
no, we can't let this happen.
So in a sense,
they big footed it.
They almost did what Essentia.
Now, he might say,
no, actually, it
was right at the 11th
hour and 59th minute
because there was this
10-day or two-week period.
But they basically, Vitalik
Buterin even did kind of what
Essentia did at that moment.
AUDIENCE: They forked
it then, right?
GARY GENSLER: I don't even know.
Was it a technical fork
because of how they did it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Right
at that moment.
AUDIENCE: Ethereum classic
still has the DAO--
GARY GENSLER: The
stolen $50 million
or whatever, the
number of tokens.
So that led to the fork.
The majority of the
community went with Vitalik
rather than what
the fork happened.
So how immutable is immutable
if there's a broad consensus?
Now that's the
backdoor, in a sense.
Second-- was there another hand?
I'm sorry, Brodish.
AUDIENCE: I think
the [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: To address
Kelly's and Zann's.
AUDIENCE: And the
word blockchain.
GARY GENSLER: And
the word blockchain.
All right.
AUDIENCE: So I think when people
are talking about blockchain
as a term, they're
essentially referring
to a set of potential
benefits of this technology.
And some of them can be relevant
for a particular use case.
Some of them might
[INAUDIBLE],, some of them
might actually [INAUDIBLE]
for that particular use case.
So the way it can
be thought of is
that we have an umbrella term
which talks about referring
potential benefits.
We take what is
[? referred ?] from that.
It could be append-only, it
could be not append-only,
it could be consensus,
it could be permission,
permissionless, whatever.
And then we cannot calibrate
with them and create a solution
which is applicable for the
particular use case that I want
to look at.
That is why even if
it is not immutable,
it is still a potential
use of blockchain,
from my understanding.
Because we are bringing up some
of the benefits of the umbrella
term.
GARY GENSLER: I
think you're correct,
but I'm not going to go all
the way to where you are.
I think you're correct
that, broadly speaking,
many people are using
this term to promote
their own innovation, the
innovation of their colleagues,
and so forth.
And yet, some want a
backdoor, like Essentia,
and make it less immutable.
And so all of a sudden,
if it has a big backdoor
and you can amend, is it really
an append-only log any longer?
What I do want to say is, in
this class, I am going to say,
anything you're working
on for your final paper,
it has to be at least a
permissioned or permissionless
system.
Thus it has to have a--
what's that?
AUDIENCE: Not mine.
GARY GENSLER: Not yours?
But you're going to get there.
You're going to
get there, Brodish.
You're going to get there.
Since I told you earlier
in the day, get to yes.
But if it's a
traditional database,
I'm saying stretch your minds,
try to figure out something.
Even if it's got a
little bit of risk
into it as to how you get
to using append-only logs,
and even in a permissioned
closed loose private consensus,
but some consensus.
Think about whether
you use a token that
gets the permissionless.
Uh-oh.
Eric's going to plead his case.
AUDIENCE: I'm just going to try
to completely reconcile this.
GARY GENSLER: And then
I need to keep going.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Those two apparently
divergent points--
GARY GENSLER: Right,
Brotish and Alin.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I actually
agree with Brotish.
AUDIENCE: The point is that--
GARY GENSLER: That he
might agree with him.
AUDIENCE: I'm
still in the middle
because from a technical
standpoint, it's true.
You have append-only log
in a consensus mechanism
that make up the
original use case that
brought the term blockchain.
GARY GENSLER: Plus a
native token in that one.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, of course.
[INAUDIBLE] But to the
point, though, what
happens if you want to
change or amend the log?
Then is that really
a blockchain?
That's exactly the reason
why the term [INAUDIBLE]
later technologies came up.
Because to a certain
purist extent,
it's not an append-only
log because you're actually
updating it from a
purist definition.
That makes sense, of course.
But then the nature of
a distributed database
that's not located
in an intranet
that governs the updates and
whatever changes you make it,
it's the reason that make up
these ledger technologies that
are blockchain
inspired, if you may.
So it's OK, you can say
if you amend the log,
then it's not blockchain.
Right, but it's DLT, and the
DLT is blockchain inspired.
So we can keep everything
in the neighborhood.
GARY GENSLER: We're going
to keep this discussion
and debate going.
And we're probably
not all that far off.
It's not about
vocabulary, it's also
about I'm trying to spur you all
to get to yes, even if you're
a minimalist.
Think about some project that
uses the essence of this,
and not just inspired.
So then what are the specifics
of this append-only log
and consensus use case
or blockchain use case?
So what cost of
verification or networking
are you actually reducing?
Back to Catalini's work
about verification cost
and networking costs that
we talked about on Tuesday.
What is that cost you're
actually reducing?
Which transactions
need to be recorded?
What accounts or
transactions, you might say,
need to be recorded on this log?
What stakeholders need
to be able to write?
If there's only one stakeholder
that needs to update something,
I'm not really entirely
sure that you'd
be in this distributed
decentralized place.
So I list these questions
that weren't directly
in the readings, but
I list these questions
to say this is a way to start
to get your mind around where
this technology,
however we label it,
this technology can help.
In essence, does it lower cost
of verification and networking?
And if so, which ones?
Which ones are you
trying to address?
Which ones are you trying
to dig and basically create
value for your startup?
What transactions or accounts
are you trying to record?
Transactions, like
changing property rights
or moving around birth
records or land records
or supply chain.
But where's that?
Which stakeholders actually need
to write to this distributed
ledger?
Because if it's only one party--
I'm still trying to get my head
around why the Australian Stock
Exchange really
needs it, but OK.
What is it that
multiple parties need
to write to this shared
collective state of what
is there?
And then the last one is
also terribly important,
is, what's the customer
user interface?
And a lot of challenges
are basically like,
currently we're not
in a place where
a lot of blockchain
applications are distributed,
applications have great
customer user interfaces.
But that as well.
Then what are the cost
of the transitions?
Akira mentioned this
from the Geneva Report
and the other readings.
But what are the
costs and challenges?
Well, of course, we still
have a bunch of scalability
and performance issues.
We have the privacy
issues and coordination.
I'm not trying to hold us
all to that, by the way,
for your final projects.
If we're not going to get to
scalability for five or seven
years, I'm not
going to say, well,
then you all have to write
about permissioned systems.
No.
I'm OK if you say,
well, this is a pilot
and somebody else
is going to solve
through layer two or
zk-SNARKs or something,
these other things.
But I'd like you to
at least identify
what are the issues
of scalability,
performance, privacy, security,
those issues that might
hold your implementation out.
Can a permissioned
blockchain adequately
addresses whatever
the use case is?
And how can you actually
jump start broad adoption?
That's your network challenges.
How, when you start Uber,
can you get a lot of people
to use your Uber app?
But in this case, if I can
use that consumer credit--
I thought the consumer credit
idea was really a neat one.
Maybe it could go right at the
heart of a lot of market power.
But now, how do you get
all the auto dealers,
how do you get
all the employers,
how do you get the
banks to actually say,
I want to get rid of First
Union and I want the Blockchain
and Money final project team's--
and by the way, just replacing
one central monopolist
with another central monopolist,
a lot of commercial banks
aren't terribly
excited about that.
Maybe you're going to have
to give some ownership.
Maybe you'll have to give
50% of your ownership
to the 20 banks that
are now a part of this.
There are other ways to
build incentive systems.
Maybe you put a
native token in there
and you give them
the native token.
So there may be
other incentive ways
to beat the current monopolist.
But having been around
commercial banks
for a long time, they
really are looking for ways
to replace their aggregators
and their back office,
whether it's clearing,
settlement, exchanges, credit
agencies.
But they are deeply
understanding--
because they are pretty
ambitious and very
good at making money
as well, they deeply
understand that every idea
that's pitched to them
is somebody who
currently is small
but wants to get big
and gain market power.
So they're also always
thinking about how
to ensure that there's
a check to slow down
your startup from gaining
market power 5, 10,
and 15 years from now.
They don't want you to be
the next Clearinghouse,
like the Chicago Mercantile
Exchange or Intercontinental
Exchange.
They don't want you to be the
next central node of market
power.
So you might share
some of that with them,
or you might find
an incentive system.
And then what are the net?
So key questions for companies
designing blockchains.
This is something from MIT's
own Sloan Management Review.
It was not a required
reading, but I
thought it was a nice
little way to do it.
What are you trying to do?
Are you trying to
record something?
Track something?
Verify something?
Aggregate something?
This was in the Fall MIT Review.
What value do you
want to capture?
Literally, here's a
list of the things
you might want to capture.
Is it about contracts?
Is it about permissioned?
What is the value we're trying
to capture and for whom?
Obviously, is it for suppliers
or customers and so forth?
So it's another slice by
thoughtful people, MIT.
That's a link to the reading
if you do want to read it.
It was a well-written
five page article.
I even held back on one reading.
So the benefits of blockchain--
we reviewed this last Tuesday,
so I'm not going to
go through it again.
But again, as you're
thinking about this
and thinking about which
use cases and so forth,
think of these costs
of verification.
Which of these are you
really trying to hit?
Or is it networking?
And I changed the
networking a little bit,
but a token incentive system,
which could be like the skins,
rewards, and affinity,
identity could help
you start it up or operate it.
Or it could be
like CryptoKitties,
where it's like a collectible.
So that's another
way that you have
token economics floating in.
So this you've seen.
I've flipped it
around, but basically,
do you use a
traditional database?
Do you think about a
private blockchain?
Do you think about
a public blockchain?
If you're over here, I really
ask you, Brodish, you've
got to get to yes.
You've got to get to here.
You wouldn't want me
to just be teaching
a traditional database, how do
you build something in Sloan,
right?
This is blockchained money.
Or as Alin wants me to relabel
it, append-only logs, consensus
protocols, and money.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And a native currency.
GARY GENSLER: And
a native currency.
But how many of
you would sign up?
Would you recommend
that I list it
in the course catalog that
way for next September?
AUDIENCE: No.
GARY GENSLER: Really?
No, not really.
All right.
But if you want to really
juice, get to here.
Put an append-only log
in there and some even
private permissioned system.
Or be bold.
Try to get all the way to there.
Don't stay there, please.
All right.
I've made my point.
James.
Where are you?
Are you there or there?
AUDIENCE: I think I'm in the
middle, private blockchain.
GARY GENSLER: Ah, come on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: All right.
Good.
Yeah, but they're going
to get at least to there.
They're not staying there,
they want to get a good grade.
[LAUGHTER]
No, no.
Really, this is going to be fun.
Listen, I get it.
It's not just like any
Sloan class, where you
have a final and everything.
I've given you a hard test.
There's $30 billion chasing
around to try to find uses.
There's thousands-- 2,500 at IBM
or whatever-- there's thousands
of people trying to do this.
And there's no really true
market-wide applications
right now.
But that's the nature of what
we're doing here together.
And I'm not asking
that somebody actually
be able to go raise money
and actually start it.
You don't have to code
it, except for you, Alin.
But you don't have to
actually code this thing.
But I'm really looking
for your business savvy,
and it's more about
critical reasoning skills.
And these four or five
pages, pull it off of Canvas
and think about it,
think about how it fits
in with your projects or not.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Given that-- well,
the question in previous slides
are helpful.
But I still find it's hard to
decide whether we should really
use blockchain
database [INAUDIBLE]
traditional database.
So is there a non-technical
model or framework that we can
[INAUDIBLE] between those two?
GARY GENSLER: I think of it--
I apologize if to go back to
the slides, so I'll try not to.
But I think about it
as, are you moving
around something of value?
Do you need multiple
people to be
able to help in that network?
Because it's peer to peer.
If it were the 80 or
90 of us in this room,
you might be just
there right now,
that there's a benefit
of that peer to peer
movement of something of value.
Or frankly, even back
to this, if there's
a lot of economic rents.
If there's market power
in this, if there's
big market power and somebody
is just collecting lots,
that might be your opportunity
because this is the technology
that can get you there.
And you might say,
well, I don't absolutely
have to have an append-only
consensus native currency
type of technology, but it's
how I get to peer to peer.
So it might be
that that's the way
that I'm going to
disrupt the party
with the big economic rents.
Like the letter to
Jamie Dimon, if there's
a bunch of things
about censorship risk.
And again, I don't know what
use cases you're thinking about.
But I think if
you don't have one
of these six, the
verification costs,
it's unlikely you need an
append-only log and consensus
in the whole mechanism.
But I think if you do have
something here, hopefully not
just economic rents
but market power,
this might be the way you
get underneath it, by having
a decentralized peer
to peer approach.
So if that helps.
And it could be something that
has no central authority right
now, no central intermediary,
and it's just how
to jump start something.
I think in that
circumstance, it's
more likely you
need a native token.
I think if you're trying
to jump start a network--
and there's a lot of
collective action reasons
that will still face you.
Some of our colleagues,
Andy Lippman
and others over at the Media
Lab, spent a lot of time
a year, year and a half ago
on a medical records approach
with Beth Israel
Hospital locally here.
And if Andy were here,
he'd say, but I still
have the collective
action issues.
How do I get a
bunch of hospitals
and a bunch of
doctors and how do I
get all that collective
action to work together
to use one database
system, if you wish?
So I think to get over that
collective action issue,
you start getting into,
well, this native token
might be an interesting
way to do that.
AUDIENCE: Right.
It seemed that Uber satisfied
the things you just mentioned.
GARY GENSLER: They did.
They did.
But would they have
done it differently
if they started in
a different era?
I don't know.
It's remarkable that they
took on and just completely
transformed the ride
share business, the taxi
business, if you wish.
But I'm pretty
confident of this,
there will be
something that we don't
envision right now that really
transforms the next thing.
As my brother said
when he said, it
might be five and
10 years from now
and you won't even expect it.
Who would have thought
the internet in the 1990s
was going to go straight and
transform the taxi business?
Nobody in the New
York Taxi business
would have envisioned that,
which was one of the things
that he mentioned.
So why use blockchain
versus traditional database?
We did that.
I know, you got it got, Brodish?
Right there?
OK.
No, I'm having some fun.
So the trade-offs we've talked
about, so these are costs.
This is the cost
of centralization
versus decentralization.
We've looked at
this slide before.
I think this was an
earlier question.
Over time, I think
what's going to happen
is these graphs might
have different slopes.
So it's just like, OK,
what if the slopes change?
I think that the cost
of decentralization
are going to come down.
But that's more my
forecasting prognostication.
And then you'll have
more applications
that feel more comfortable
over using something
around this space.
Now, I could be wrong and
it could go the other way.
Just saying.
And this would be more of
the minimalist side and says,
well, you can address some
of those centralization costs
and it comes down the other way.
So it's just a
visual way to think
about what will happen
over time with innovation.
But I think innovation
will pull down
the slope towards that from
where we are today because
of the newer technology,
this decentralized
how can we do this.
And I think there will be
more opportunities around it.
All right.
So on the 30th, we're
going to be talking
about basically our first area.
We're going to talk
about payments.
a lot about payments.
I'm going to take two days
to talk about payments.
So we're going to lay
out a lot about what's
going on in finance outside of
append-only logs and consensus
protocols and blockchain.
But we're going to have
fun because what we all
live together.
And some of you actually
live in these countries.
But whether it's Alipay,
[INAUDIBLE],, and M-Pesa, so
all these initiatives.
And then how could maybe
blockchain fit into it?
In terms of the use cases,
these are all those use cases
that we're going to be doing
from October 30 to December 6.
But this gives you a sense,
what I call Act Three.
And we're going to
really be trying
to challenge each other about--
some weeks, I'm going
to give you a heads up,
it's going to be a little thin.
I'm going to be
looking for who's
got really good use cases.
If you have something to
bring into the classroom
that you're saying,
hey, this reading
list I put together
in late August--
and by November, it
might be that there's
somebody that's actually
moved something further.
So don't be bashful.
Shoot it into me in time
and I'll distribute it
to the whole class.
But in a couple of places,
digital ID, for instance,
I thought it was thin.
There's the Estonia case,
but it's not really--
not sure it's a blockchain.
I'm admitting in
advance, some of these
are a little thin
but still good.
And the readings for the 30th--
the Federal Reserve
Payment Study really
shows a bunch of information.
And you have to read the words,
just look at the few charts.
But it's going to
give you trends.
You're going to really see some
interesting trends in there.
What the best mobile apps are,
and the global payment report,
and things like that.
Any questions on any of that?
And then what did we talk about?
Blockchain technology
can address costs
through verification
and networking.
The potential use cases--
the devil is in the detail.
It's true in most
things in life,
but it really is these
natty little details
about what transactions,
who am I going
to try to disintermediate, where
am I going to create value,
why use a permissioned
or permissionless
blockchain rather than
a traditional database,
and really get some value.
I think you really have
to address this question,
but I think there's
potential there.
Or why a public blockchain
versus a private?
Is a token going to help
you jump start something?
And remember, there's two
different types of tokens.
There's the broad
currency type token.
That might be Bitcoin, and they
might have won the whole thing,
or it'll be somebody else, or
there might be two or three.
I personally don't think
there'll be hundreds of those.
But then there might
be, in essence,
use case-specific tokens.
Right now we have 1,600,
and most will fail.
So that's it.
Any other queries or anything?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Once all the bitcoins
are mined in 2040 or 2030--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: 2040.
GARY GENSLER: But by 2040, it's
a very slow inflation curve.
It's probably a
slow inflation curve
in the middle of the 2030s.
AUDIENCE: The
incentives, if there
will continue to be
incentives for node operators
to continue operating
benevolently, if there's
no further incentives--
GARY GENSLER: So the question
is, what happens in 20--
when there's very
few mining rewards?
And the answer is--
I'm going to have some
fun with you here.
I'm going to show
you one other thing.
The answer is, yes,
because it's fees.
And the fees in the system--
I apologize.
It's just one thing that I
want to show you that's fun.
The fees in the system--
so right now you can have
fees, if you remember how
there are fees in the system.
And instead of having
mining rewards,
right now there are
very small fees.
So for every transaction
you put into Bitcoin,
you can actually say,
instead of taking at exactly
that the inputs
equal the outputs,
you have inputs greater than the
outputs, and the net is fees.
And what is the case
there is that in 2030
or something like
that, I think the fees
will continue to increase,
I think, if this takes off.
The question is,
does it take off?
So I just had some fun because
this day is an important day
for me since you met him.
So whom is whom?
[LAUGHTER]
I sent this picture
to Rob this morning
because today is our birthday.
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: (SINGING)
Happy birthday to you--
GARY GENSLER: No, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
That's all right.
AUDIENCE: (SINGING)
Happy birthday to you.
GARY GENSLER: No, no, no, no.
AUDIENCE: (SINGING) Happy
birthday, dear Gary.
Happy birthday to you.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY GENSLER: So who's who?
AUDIENCE: You're in the white.
GARY GENSLER: White in
striped shirt or not?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Solid.
AUDIENCE: Your stripes.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
How many striped shirters?
All right.
How many solid shirters?
Wow.
So I sent it to
Rob this morning,
and I sent it to
my three daughters,
and I sent it to my girlfriend.
I said, who is this?
It's split view there, too.
[LAUGHTER]
I went with striped shirt,
but Rob said he doesn't know.
[LAUGHTER]
We were three years old there.
So that's just a
goof around with you.
All right.
Thank you all.